what would you tell an actor who's armed
with a degree from a wonderful school in
theater 21:22
ready to set the world on fire they come
here in that same mindset what what
would you tell that person you know I
will tell that person find a way to
perform live something that you are
going to be great in and find a way to
get as many people as possible to come
watch you live whether it's a hole in
the wall in Hollywood or in the valley
or on the west side wherever that is and
get people to come don't take no for an
answer see you perform directors
producers writers casting directors
agents to come see your work as opposed
to a tape that possibly they could fast
forward there's nothing that's going to
be as powerful as somebody seeing you do
the work in person
you